The answer is red.
In addition to the two parameters being passed between parentheses,
which of course get bound to the input parameters, one and two.
I'm now passing a third parameter by calling that function on the right side of
a dot access for property look up.
The value that appears on the left of that dot will automatically be
given the name, this, inside of that function invocation.
This behavior is useful if we plan on doing much object oriented programming,
since there will usually be a relevant focal object for any given method call.
And that object generally appears to the left of
the dot when the method gets called.